haley bieber is setting the record
straight after a fan video of her and
her hubby justin bieber goes viral
yeah that's me the 24 year old model
took to her insta stories on wednesday
posting this puckered up pick with
justin
writing reminiscing on how amazing last
weekend was
had the best time surrounded by so much
love
i think she's great haley doubled down
on her amazing weekend
adding quote any other narrative
floating around is beyond false
don't feed into the negative [ __ ]
peeps
haley seems to be responding to a video
that went viral where fans seem to think
justin is yelling at haley
as they walk through a casino in a las
vegas hotel
the clip which was originally posted to
tick tock and has since been deleted
is making its rounds on twitter justin
is seen looking
animated using his hands while he
appears to be heated while talking to
his wife
while some people on social media
thought justin was being aggressive and
yelling
others noted that he had just gotten off
stage after performing
and was hyped up and feeding off
adrenaline i'm having a good time
the 27 year old pop star had several
performances in sin
city over the weekend including one in
honor of the opening of restaurant
delilah
at wynn las vegas he also attended the
ufc
246 fight that's about it
but this vegas getaway isn't the only
trip the lovebirds have taken lately
last month they dressed to impress for
their meeting with the president of
france
the sorry singer shared this snap from
their meeting with the politician
and his wife at the president's office
on the annual music day in france
and prior to that trip haley and justin
traveled to the city of lights for his
27th birthday in march
back in may a source told et that the
power couple has quote
found their groove after nearly three
years of marriage
adding that they're not in any rush to
have kids
justin and haley are doing amazing and
are so
solid they've really found their groove
as a married couple
and are enjoying their time together the
source added that haley is
super career driven and they aren't
focused on starting a family
yet quote of course they have talked
about their future and building a family
together
someday but both of them are busy with
work right now and haley really wants to
build up her youtube channel
the two of them are very supportive of
each other
[Music]
you